hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in on duties his work of stoic ethics in
book one where Cicero is discussing the
virtues he talks about courage with
which he associates greatness of soul or
magnanimity elevation is how it's
sometimes translated in the English and
one of the key questions that he is
grappling with one that he faced himself
you might say existentially is whether
you can display this this virtue of
courage better in public or in private
life and what we mean there is whether
you're engaging in your own affairs or
whether you are engaging in something
that's that's bigger than you generally
he's thinking about the affairs of the
nation but we might think about say
local government or being involved
within corporate governance or or any
sort of thing where you're exercising
power and dealing with other
organizations and people and probably
also competing for power and hopefully
rightly using it as opposed to just
doing your own thing where where you are
your own boss and you are in much
greater control over you know what
you're preoccupied with and this is a
really important question for somebody
like Cicero who's very civically minded
who had a role in governance at the
highest level in Rome so let's see what
he has to say towards the end of this
discussion in book 1 he says we must
decide that the most important
activities those most indicative of a
great spirit are performed by the men
who direct the affairs of nations for
such public activities to have the
widest scope and touch the lives of most
people so he's saying that you have a
greater capacity or scope for displaying
courage and greatness of soul in the
public sphere at the same time he
continues and he says
even in the life of retirement there are
and have been many high sold people who
have been engaged in important inquiries
or embarked on most important
enterprises and yet kept themselves
within the limits of their own affairs
or and here he has himself in mind in
some respect
taking a middle course between
philosophers on the one hand and
statesmen on the other they were content
with managing their own property not
increasing it by any and every means nor
de barring their kindred from the
enjoyment of it but rather if there were
need sharing it with their friends and
with the state cicero of course did not
confine himself to that sort of
individual or you know family economic
activity but he did find himself forced
into retirement out of political life
and then embarked upon his project that
this book is a part of you know writing
all of this this philosophy translating
greek philosophy into a latin and
specifically roman context which turns
out to be one of his greatest
contribution so you could say well is
that public or is that private and
that's that's a good question here let's
talk first as we're thinking about this
in terms of what he's calling retirement
and and we typically think about
retirement as leaving the workplace and
just doing your own thing he has
something similar in mind but it doesn't
mean a life of inactivity it could be a
life that is devoted to managing your
own property and affairs it could be a
life in which you're engaged in say
artistic production or you are writing
books or you know doing individual
things and he says that this is in many
respects easier to manage it's easier to
not succumb to the kinds of obstacles
and temptations that that stand in the
way of being courageous or great-souled
what would those be so for example
dealing with other people who want
to also be in charge that can provoke
emotions fear anger desire aversion
these sorts of things that the Stoics
we're quite concerned about and you'll
remember that Cicero says that courage
is not simply mastering fear but it also
involves a freedom from other you know
vexing emotions particularly anger we
might include rivalry and envy among
them as well so if you're in private
life provided you're not trying to
compare yourself against all the others
you know and and somehow like supplant
all of them in which you're kind of
involved in a public life it's it's
easier for the individual to manage the
requirements of courage and gratefulness
but there's less opportunities for one
to shine certainly to to do more on a
higher level if you confine yourself to
your own little patch of ground to
cultivate your own garden as the
expression goes well you can display it
within that that that confines but you
can't display it in other ways and so
there's kind of a trade-off there if we
look instead to public life where where
Cicero does think courage it has a much
better chance to be not necessarily
cultivated but displayed here there's
much greater opportunity because we're
talking about bigger challenges and
we're also talking about the problem of
dealing with others as well who may be
vying rivaling you know contending with
you about who gets the power or who you
know gets to shine as the great example
sometimes people get quite worked up not
not just about you know who's in charge
but who gets the credit who gets the
glory and so there's there's more
opportunity but there's also more
difficulty because once you're in the
public sphere you have much less control
over the life that you're leading Cicero
is a prime example of this you know he
lived in a time that was extraordinarily
contentious first he lived through the
you know Marius and sulla disorders
going on within Rome and even you know
social wars and then he lived through
this this sort of power shake-up that
eventually coalesced around the
triumvirate of Caesar Pompey and Crassus
which he was invited to join as a fourth
but but refused and then he saw that
break apart and a new civil war take
place and so you know he did not have
the opportunity to shape everything the
way he might have chosen to but really
nobody did and so so he talks about this
is quite a bit in here he he brings up
some examples of different people who
you know engaged it important affairs
and then he brings up another question
right or another issue
well what's required in order to
genuinely be courageous in public life
and here we have to think about the very
definition or characterization of
courage as Cicero brings it out and this
he's deriving again from the Stoics when
courage the this drive for independence
for rulership for you know facing
dangers is not guided by justice and
wisdom it ceases to be courage and
starts to become vices instead and he
saw that happening within the public
life of his own time and he's got plenty
of examples from Greek history and
earlier Roman history as well so that's
one thing Cicero will actually talk
about this in terms of the common good
in in private life you can be concerned
with your own individual or say family
or however you want to put it it could
be a good and philosophy
your profession you can be concerned
with that more specific or a particular
good but if you are taking care of the
affairs of a nation you're not supposed
to be just enriching yourself and and
consolidating your own position
that's not genuine courage there's a
kind of daring or cunning there but it's
not courageous Cicero says that unless
you're concerned with the the common
good which includes that of the common
people you are not really displaying
courage so you would have to develop
that capacity and you would have to
resist those quite quite common
temptations that that come along in
addition to this one would have to have
a mastery which requires an
understanding of the emotions so as not
to be as I mentioned not to be just able
to face fear but able to face one's
desires and ones to be able to take on
pain and endure it and to not be misled
by pleasures and of course to not
confuse one's feeling of anger with
genuine courage and to try to minimize
anger as much as possible that was
that's what it would be required in
order to be a good state's person now
Cicero also raises another very
important question we tend to associate
courage with war or conflict and so it
might be natural to think that war
offers us the best opportunity for
developing and for displaying courage as
opposed to times of peace
Cicero makes a really interesting
argument to say no courage is not only
required in both of these circumstances
but also needs to be developed for times
of peace you might say it's even more
necessary although in a different way
at that time so he says most people
think achievements of war are more
important than that of peace but this
opinion needs to be corrected so how
does he do that he says many men have
sought occasions for war from the mere
ambition for fame people don't seek out
occasions for peace for fame and so war
has a tendency to seduce us too
to lead us astray and he says this is a
big problem for people of great spirit
and natural ability it's more likely to
happen if they are adapted to a
soldier's life and fond of warfare and
then he says if we actually look at how
things turn out right if we if we judge
if we want to judge rightly he says
we'll find there have been many
instances of achievement in peace more
important and no less renowned than in
war interestingly some of these have to
do with the very preparation and you
might say groundwork that made certain
countries successful in war he gives us
an example the the Spartans right he
says if you think about Pausanias and
listen door to Spartan Kings although it
might be thought that if it was by their
achievements Sparta gained their
supremacy these are not even to be
compared with the legislation and
discipline of like her guess like her
guess was the person who gave the
structure gave the way of life a brutal
one by the way to the Spartans and so he
laid a sort of groundwork Cicero himself
talks about his own experience in this
this book very briefly trying to hold
the Roman Republic in its last days
together and he says this was you know
me operating in a time of peace it
actually took you know a lot of work and
hardship on my part
and he says arms are of little value in
the field unless there's wise counsel
at home and so this is this a very
important point we can display courage
just as much in public life through how
we conduct ourselves in peace how we
maintain peace how we bring peace how we
build the state or the city or indeed
whatever other institution we're talking
about just as much as we can in war so
we don't want to be misled into thinking
that courage is really just the
warrior's virtue it's also required for
the Statesman for the leader for the
person who is going to try to reconcile
the many discordant voices and demands
of a body of people and try to bring
some sort of at least hopefully
temporary but perhaps even lasting
harmony to those ends desires and
demands so where do we see courage it
can be shown in both public and private
life but Cicero thinks that public life
in some respects has a greater call for
us and he wants to stress this is what
I'll wrap up with that when we see a
need for courage to be displayed genuine
courage in public life and if we have
those capacities within ourselves we
ought to step up and respond
you